Hmm
[Music]
How far are you going?
Now, it's time to return depending on the base
.
[Music]
I've been worried, but I'm okay if I'm fine, but I
'm sorry, but I'll be back soon.
Magazine
yeah
[  Music]
Ah, I said I was dressing in color, but when I tried to return things to Yuri from the beginning, I went to Itohodo as if I was
caught.
Teacher good Katashima rented house What is good?
No, I don't heal the embarrassing things
that I
don't do.
It's gut, but surfing is an important new thing. I
'm very interested in the teacher
who is obsessed with it.
Even if I want it separately, I don't want to take it away. I
just want to share the same thing. I want to be the same.
For example, my lover's review.
I and Sawabe are just fish and
assistants.
It's important for the teacher to surf, so let's
not get it out. What if the mule takes care of the teacher here? You
'll get angry.
I'm not robbed by the god of the world, but
I'll tear it off with the teacher,
then I laughed, I won't touch it, and the flow that comes through.